.
Es ist einer der
am schlechtesten bezahlten Berufe
mit unmöglichen Arbeitsbedingungen.
Ein sehr anstrengender
und ein typischer Frauenberuf.
Frauen, die oft keine Anerkennung und
keine Wertschätzung dafür bekommen,
dass sie
den Dreck der anderen wegmachen.
In der Schweiz
sind die meisten über 55-jährigen
Putzfrauen Portugiesinnen.
Ohne Ausbildung oder Papiere
war dieser Job damals
die einzig mögliche Beschäftigung.
Für einen lächerlichen Lohn
haben sie ihr ganzes Leben
in der Schweiz gekehrt,
geschrubbt und gefegt.
Wenn es um den Ruhestand geht,
wird klar,
dass ihre Rente nicht reichen wird,
um hier zu leben.
Zurück in ihr Heimatland,
das wissen sie,
wäre die bestmögliche Lösung.
Es ist aber schwieriger,
als man denkt.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
(Journalistin) Manuela, machen Sie
den Beruf als Putzfrau schon lange?
24 Jahre.
Seit 24 Jahren bin ich
Hauswartin in diesem Gebäude,
und es gefällt mir.
Es ist nicht super ...
... aber die Leute
sind zufrieden und es ist sauber.
Achtung, Monsieur, es ist rutschig,
guten Morgen.
Respektieren die Leute Ihre Arbeit?
Einige schon ja.
Einige erkennen meine Arbeit an.
Von ihnen erhalte ich Ende Jahr
schöne Geschenke.
Andere nicht.
Die sehen meine Arbeit gar nicht,
verschmutzen die Scheiben,
werfen Papier auf den Boden
und lassen es liegen,
anstatt es in den Müll zu werfen.
Ohne Respekt.
Und wenn ich sie nicht grüsse,
grüssen sie mich nicht.
Macht Ihnen das etwas aus?
Ja, klar,
ich bin schliesslich auch jemand.
Ich schäme mich nicht
für meine Arbeit,
aber gewisse meinen,
sie seien etwas Besseres.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Es ist ein gewöhnlicher Montag
in einem gewöhnlichen Leben,
der mit putzen verbracht wurde.
Zuerst bei privaten,
jetzt in diesen Genfer Gebäuden.
Au revoir, bonne journée.
Manuela Marmelo, 56-jährig,
portugiesische Putzfrau -
wie viele aus ihrer Generation.
Viele Leute schämen sich.
Aber ich nicht.
Mein Beruf war nie ein Geheimnis.
Ich sagte nie,
dass ich in einem Büro,
im Coop oder in der Migros
arbeiten würde.
Putzfrau ist Putzfrau.
Wie früher vom einen zum anderen
zu rennen, war ermüdend.
Zu Hause angekommen, hatte ich
meine Familie, meinen Haushalt,
das war ebenfalls ermüdend.
Jetzt ist es anders,
jetzt habe ich nur noch zwei.
Zwei Arbeitgeber?
Ja, und da fühle ich mich wohl.
Ich stehe morgens auf
und freue mich auf meine Arbeit.
Ich beklage mich nicht,
im Gegensatz zu anderen.
Das kann ich nicht.
Ich habe Glück und hoffe,
dass es bis zu meiner Pensionierung
weiter so läuft
und ich meine Arbeit behalten kann.
Manuela hätte niemals gedacht,
sich Sorgen um ihre Rente
machen zu müssen,
als sie in eines der reichsten Länder
Europas einwanderte.
Das war vor 36 Jahren.
Mit 20 kam sie aus Portugal
in die Schweiz,
zu ihrem Mann,
der als Maler arbeitete
und sich damals schon
in Genf niedergelassen hatte.
In den 80er-Jahren
brauchte man billige Arbeitskräfte.
Deshalb wanderten viele Portugiesen
in die Schweiz aus.
Erinnern Sie sich
an den Tag Ihrer Abreise?
Ja. Sogar daran,
wie ich angezogen war.
Wollen Sie es uns erzählen?
Ich trug eine dunkelblaue Latzhose
und ein Hemd mit roten Blümchen.
Es war hart, mein Land zu verlassen.
Und meine Schwester,
die ich sehr lieb hatte -
sie war meine zweite Mama.
Aber ja, ich kam,
um mit meinem Mann zusammenzuleben.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Diese Puderdose begleitet mich seit
Jahren während meiner Ferien.
Meine Tochter
schreibt mir jeweils was rein:
"Ich liebe dich, Mama.
Schöne Ferien, du wirst mir fehlen."
Diesmal zeichnete sie ein Herzchen.
Ich liebe meine Tochter.
Manuela lebt alleine
in dieser Wohnung von der Firma,
die sie sich nur
dank des Hauswartsjobs leisten kann.
Wie viele Portugiesinnen
hätte sie niemals gedacht,
so lange in der Schweiz zu bleiben.
Ich dachte,
ich würde erst mal herkommen,
um dann doch eines Tages wieder
zu Hause in Portugal zu leben.
Wir stellten uns vor,
dass wir zurückgehen würden,
bevor die Kinder eingeschult werden.
Sie sind doch hier
zur Schule gegangen.
Ich bin geblieben
und bin immer noch hier.
On y va.
Wie Manuela sind viele der
immigrierten Portugiesinnen
aus den 80ern geblieben.
Heute machen sie 12 %
der Schweizer Bevölkerung aus.
* Folkloristische
Tamburin- und Akkordeonklänge *
* Sie singt auf Portugiesisch. *
Freitagabend in Genf.
Ein Mini-Portugal
inmitten der Industriezone.
Die portugiesische Community ist eine
der integriertesten in der Schweiz
und gleichzeitig bleibt sie
ihrer Kultur und Folklore treu.
Alleine in Genf gibt es
ca. 40 solcher Gemeinschaften.
Jeden Freitag nach ihrer Arbeit
kommt Maria hierher.
Hier findet sie ihr Land,
das sie verlassen hat,
und die bei den Portugiesen starke
Tradition des Familienclans, wieder.
* Fröhliche, traditionelle,
portugiesische Musik *
* Maria singt auf Portugiesisch. *
Man fühlt sich
ein wenig wie zu Hause.
Wir geben diese Tradition von
Generation zu Generation weiter.
Schon meine Grosseltern
waren Teil davon.
Leider kann ich sie nicht mit ihnen,
dafür mit meiner Mama teilen.
Wie ist es, sie singen zu sehen?
Ich glaube, das erlaubt ihr,
ein wenig auszubrechen
und nicht so viel
an ihre Arbeit zu denken.
Ich freue mich für sie.
Und jetzt gehen Sie tanzen?
Normalerweise singe ich,
aber ich werde versuchen,
ein bisschen zu tanzen.
* Fröhliche, traditionelle Musik *
Maria hat sich in der Schweiz
ein Leben aufgebaut.
Familie, Hobbys, Arbeit.
Die Schweiz
ist zu ihrem Land geworden.
Am Anfang war das nicht einfach.
Im Flugzeug sagte mir mein Mann:
"Du wirst sehen, wie schön es
in Genf ist, es gibt einen See."
Ich antwortete: "Um das Wasser
zu sehen, gehe ich an den Strand."
Es war sehr hart am Anfang.
Da hatte ich noch keine Arbeit.
Er ging arbeiten,
und ich fühlte mich sehr alleine.
Einsamkeit ist nicht gut für mich.
Wenn mein Mann arbeiten ging,
stand ich am Fenster,
schaute auf die Berge, dachte daran,
wie weit weg Portugal ist
und fing an zu weinen.
Mein Mann versteckte meinen Pass,
weil ich ihm sagte:
"Eines Tages, wenn du
nach Hause kommst, bin ich weg."
Maria ist geblieben.
30 Jahre sind es jetzt schon.
Seit 30 Jahren steht sie frühmorgens
auf, um in Firmen zu putzen
und kommt spätabends nach Hause.
Maria hat nie bei Privaten geputzt.
Sie hat immer eine offiziell
deklarierte Stelle verlangt
und ist bei einer Putzfirma
für 2 Std. pro Tag
und 20 Fr. die Stunde angestellt.
Ich wusste von Anfang an, dass
ich als Putzfrau arbeiten würde,
weil es meinen portugiesischen Beruf
hier nicht gibt.
Dort arbeitete ich in einer Fabrik,
die Trainingsanzüge herstellt.
Hier gibt's das nicht.
Ich mache es gern, aber es ist
nicht immer gut genug bezahlt.
Wenn ich einen rechten Lohn bekomme,
mache ich diese Arbeit gerne.
An einer meiner Arbeitsstellen
waren noch andere Frauen
anderer Nationalitäten.
Sie sagten zu mir: "Portugiesinnen
sind wie gemacht fürs Putzen."
"Ja, zum Glück können wir das gut",
antwortete ich.
Putzen ist ein Beruf
wie jeder andere auch.
Aber eben ...
... kein gut bezahlter.
Es können ja nicht alle
Professoren oder Ärzte sein.
Es braucht alles
in der Gesellschaft.
Man stelle sich vor,
es gäbe keine Putzfrauen.
Ich putze nur 2 Std. abends
und verdiene 700 Fr. im Monat.
Nicht mehr,
wir erhalten pro Std. 19.85 Fr.
Nach allen Abzügen
bleiben noch 15 Fr./Std.
Mehr nicht.
Normalerweise könnte man
an einem achtstündigen Tag
ungefähr 4'000 Fr. verdienen.
Aber heutzutage
vergibt kein Arbeitgeber
8 Std. Putzarbeit
an dieselbe Person.
Wir rennen von hier nach da
quer durch Genf,
um 4 oder 5 Std.
für mehrere Arbeitgeber zu arbeiten.
Aber niemals 8 Std.
für ein und denselben Arbeitgeber.
Die Putzfrauen, die in einer
Reinigungsfirma angestellt sind,
kommen nicht
auf 8 Std. Arbeit pro Tag,
weil die Arbeitgeber von gesetzlichen
Schlupflöchern profitieren.
Um Anspruch auf Pensionskassengelder
zu haben,
müssen mind. 21'300 Fr. pro Jahr beim
selben Arbeitgeber verdient werden.
Mit 2 Std. pro Woche
für je 19.85 Fr.
ist Maria weit davon entfernt, An-
recht auf ihre zweite Säule zu haben.
Für ihre Rente kann sie nur
mit ihren eigenen Einzahlungen
und ihrer AHV rechnen.
Wissen Sie,
wie hoch Ihre Rente sein wird?
Ich denke, kaum mehr als 1'000 Fr.
Um Hoffnung auf
wenigstens 1'000 Fr. Rente zu haben,
muss Maria 700 Fr.
mit einem Nebenjob verdienen.
Seit 24 Jahren steht sie
jeden Tag um 5 Uhr auf,
um die Bestellungen der Hefte für die
Kioske in der Romandie vorzubereiten.
Die portugiesische Migrationswelle
der 80er-Jahre
brachte also günstige Arbeitskräfte,
die nicht nur wenig kosteten,
sondern oftmals
auch schwarz arbeiteten -
zumindest in den Anfängen.
* Melancholische Klänge *
Das ist Isabel.
Sie ist alleine
in die Schweiz gekommen.
Sie war nie verheiratet
und hat auch keine Kinder.
Sie war auf der Suche
nach einem besseren Leben.
Als ich mit meinen Koffern
am Bahnhof ankam,
hatte ich grosse Angst, weil ich
an der Grenze gefragt wurde,
was ich in der Schweiz machen wolle.
Ich antwortete,
dass ich Urlaub bei Freunden mache.
Daraufhin konnte ich
die Grenze problemlos passieren.
Aber?
Ja, ich hatte Angst.
Wenn man mich
nicht durchgelassen hätte,
was wäre mir anderes übriggeblieben,
als wieder in meine Heimat
zurückzugehen?
Isabel wurde in den 60er-Jahren
im Norden von Portugal,
in einem kleinen Dorf
in der Nähe von Porto geboren.
Ein von Salazars Diktatur
und Abneigung gegen die Bildung
geschwächtes und verarmendes
Portugal.
* Melancholische Gitarrenklänge *
Zu dieser Zeit konnte einer von
dreien weder lesen noch schreiben.
Erst 1964 wurden die Schulen
für alle obligatorisch.
Und das auch nur für zehn Jahre.
Ein schweres Erbe
des Analphabetismus,
daher die Vielzahl der Frauen
in Haushaltsberufen.
Die Schule
begann bei uns mit sechs Jahren
und dauerte vier obligatorische
Jahre bis zehn.
Diejenigen, die finanziell
die Möglichkeit hatten,
besuchten weitere Schulen.
Die anderen eben nicht.
Ohne Ausbildung,
Arbeit und ohne Familie,
war das Exil die einzige Perspektive
für ein besseres Leben.
Nach einem Zwischenstopp
in Frankreich
kam Isabel 1992 mit 32 Jahren
in die Schweiz.
Das ist das erste Foto,
als ich in Genf ankam.
Ich ging mit einer Freundin
spazieren.
Wie finden Sie sich?
Schön.
In Genf hatte Isabelle keine Wahl.
Die einzige unmittelbar
verfügbare Arbeit,
die sie schwarz verrichten konnte,
war, bei Privaten zu putzen.
So entstand ein höllischer Rhythmus
zu Diensten anderer,
und so vergass sie
ihr eigenes Leben.
Es war sehr hart.
Ich begann um 6.30 Uhr
und arbeitete bis 21.30 oder 22 Uhr.
ohne eine freie Minute.
Ich hatte keine eigene Wohnung,
und da ich keine Papiere hatte,
musste ich diese Arbeiten annehmen.
So konnte ich wohnen und essen.
28 Jahre später - Isabel
hat mittlerweile den C-Ausweis.
Mit 60 Jahren übersteigt ihr
Bruttomonatsgehalt keine 3'200 Fr.
Ich kann nicht viel unternehmen.
Z.B. ins Kino
oder in ein Restaurant essen gehen.
Wenn ich vor einem Restaurant stehe
und nicht reingehen kann
aber andere schon,
fühle ich mich ein wenig
minderwertig.
Aber ich kann es mir
einfach nicht leisten.
Ich muss mich damit abfinden,
ich habe keine Wahl.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Wie viele Arbeitgeber
haben Sie im Moment?
Ich habe einen,
zwei,
drei,
vier,
fünf, sechs,
sieben,
acht.
Sie sind nicht alle am gleichen Ort,
dadurch verliere ich viel Zeit
mit rumfahren.
An gewissen Tagen
bin ich am Abend sehr müde.
Das alles für 3'200 Fr. pro Monat.
Selbst mit einer zweiten Säule
will man sich Isabels Rente
nicht vorstellen. Auch sie nicht.
Mit 60 Jahren hat sie keine Anfragen
für eine Rentenberechnung gestellt
und auch keine Zukunftspläne gemacht.
* Klirren *
Nicht wie immer alles kaputt machen.
Bestimmt nicht.
Nein, das tun Sie ja nicht,
alles gut.
Sie provozieren mich gerne.
Selbstverständlich,
und Sie spielen gerne mit.
Sicher, wir kennen uns
ja auch schon 20 Jahre.
Stimmt, wir zählen sie ja.
Von allen Arbeitgebern
ist Louis Keller ihr am liebsten.
Er hat sie oft unterstützt,
und er war es, der sie regelmässig
auf ihre Rente hingewiesen hat.
Ab und zu denke ich
an meine Pensionierung.
Aber nicht wirklich,
ich verdränge es.
Ich weiss ja nicht,
wie es dann sein wird.
Verdrängen ist nicht gut,
man muss sich damit beschäftigen.
Ja, ich weiss,
dass ich rechnen und planen muss.
Ja, Sie werden eine kleine Rente
haben und keine grossen Ersparnisse.
Das Leben in der Schweiz ist teuer.
Ich werde es mir
nicht erlauben können,
mit 64 mit der Arbeit aufzuhören.
Darum geht es nicht,
Sie müssen einfach daran denken,
dass Sie eine kleine Rente
und keine grossen Ersparnisse haben.
* Angespannte Klänge *
Ich frage mich schon, wie mein Leben
nach der Pensionierung sein wird.
Es ist nicht einfach
für eine alleinstehende Person.
Manchmal versuche ich zu vergessen,
aber es beschäftigt mich.
Sie denken nicht gerne daran.
- Ja, genau.
Wie viel, denken Sie,
werden Sie erhalten?
Ungefähr 1'000 Fr.,
wenn überhaupt.
Hier sind die Renten ...
Wenn man nicht viel eingezahlt hat,
gibt es nicht viel.
Ich habe nur 20,
24 Jahre.
Beiträge eingezahlt?
Ja, aber mit 1'000 Fr.
ist es unmöglich, in Genf zu leben.
* Kirchenglocken läuten. *
Ich würde gerne nach Portugal
zurückkehren.
Da könnte ich
eventuell das Haus renovieren,
also den Anteil meiner Brüder
und Schwestern aufkaufen
und dann das ganze Haus renovieren.
Wir haben Land nebenan,
somit könnte ich meinen kleinen
Gemüsegarten bewirtschaften,
kleine Tiere
wie Kaninchen und Hühner haben.
So bin ich aufgewachsen,
ich liebe dieses Leben.
Isabel ist seit fünf Jahren
nicht mehr in das Familienhaus
zurückgekehrt.
Wir schlagen ihr vor,
sie nach Portugal zu begleiten,
um einen Rentenbezug
von dort aus zu prüfen.
Vorgesehene Abreise
ist in drei Tagen.
* Maria betet auf Portugiesisch. *
Ich bin der Schweiz dankbar,
sie hat mir viel gegeben,
aber hier unter diesen schwierigen
Umständen zu leben ...
Nein, ich bevorzuge es,
nach Hause zu gehen.
Ihr Zuhause ist in diesem Haus
in Landim, Portugal.
Das Paar musste zwei Kredite
für den Kauf des Bodens
und die Finanzierung der Arbeiten
aufnehmen.
Die Rückkehr
ist also nicht per sofort.
Es ist noch nicht fertig renoviert,
weil der von uns beauftragte
Baumeister das Geld behalten hat
und wir dadurch 20'000 Euro
verloren haben.
Diesen Betrag müssen wir nun
an die Bank zurückzahlen.
Wir sind gezwungen, die Arbeiten
selber fertig zu machen.
Für mich ist es das Lebenswerk
meiner Eltern.
Ihres ganzen Lebens?
Ja, ihres ganzen Lebens.
Das ist wirklich ein grosses Opfer.
Ich will diese Arbeiten
fertig machen,
um noch zu erleben,
wie meine Eltern darin wohnen.
Bis jetzt konnten sie
nicht einen Tag
und keine einzige Nacht
darin verbringen.
Paula musste in ihrer Kindheit
Opfer erbringen: Den Bruder betreuen,
sich um die Wäsche kümmern,
damit ihre Mutter arbeiten konnte.
Paula ist immer davon ausgegangen,
dass ihre Eltern einen angenehmen und
sorglosen Ruhestand geniessen werden.
Aber wenn sie heute
ihre Ängste sieht,
wird ihr
die dramatische Situation bewusst.
Ich hörte immer wieder sagen,
dass mit der Zeit immer weniger Geld
in den Kassen sei,
weil es später weniger Löhne
geben wird.
Mir war aber nicht bewusst, dass
man von der Rente nicht leben kann.
Haben Ihre Lehrer
Sie darauf angesprochen?
Ja, sie haben uns erklärt,
in jungen Jahren zu sparen,
an die Zukunft zu denken und
uns frühzeitig darauf vorzubereiten,
obwohl die Pensionierung
noch in weiter Ferne ist.
Macht das Angst, mit 27
an die Pensionierung zu denken?
Ja, das macht ein wenig Angst.
Im Moment möchte ich an Karriere,
eine Familie und Kinder denken.
Nicht an etwas, was so viel später
im Leben sein wird.
Aber die Pensionierung
beschäftigt mich jetzt schon,
und das hat etwas Bedrückendes.
Ich dachte immer, dass die Rente
für alle 1'700 Fr. betragen würde.
Aber nein,
massgebend sind die Beitragsjahre
und wie viele Jahre
man gearbeitet hat.
Wenn die Beiträge nicht regelmässig
während 40 Jahren einbezahlt werden,
hat man keine volle Rente zugute.
Wie viele andere
kommt Maria nicht klar
mit dem System der Pensionierung.
Um eine komplette Rente von 2'370 Fr.
zu erhalten,
müssen Beiträge ab 20 ohne Unterbruch
bis 64 bzw. 65 einbezahlt werden.
Und man muss einen Jahreslohn
von 85'000 Fr. verdienen.
In anderen Worten:
Sehr wenige Leute schaffen das.
* Bedrückende Klänge *
Hallo, mein Sohn, wie geht's?
Arbeiten halt.
Es ist kalt geworden.
Wenn die Altersvorsorge bei den
Schweizerinnen Thema Nummer 1 ist,
dann ist sie es genauso
bei den eingewanderten Familien
mit der ganzen Komplexität der Zer-
rissenheit und Rückkehr in ihr Land.
Manuela ist das bewusst
und sucht mit ihren Kindern
bereits nach
möglichst schmerzfreien Lösungen.
Eine Woche
komme ich dann jeweils zu dir
und eine gehe ich
zu deiner Schwester.
Geteilter Hütedienst?
- Genau, eine Aufteilung.
Eine Woche bei mir und zwei Wochen
bei Mica. Nicht eine und eine.
Nein, nein, zwei und zwei.
- Nein, nein.
Einen Monat und einen Monat
Ein Monat ist zu lange.
- Wir werden sehen.
Wie ihr seht,
nehmen wir das Thema mit Humor.
Aber klar, wenn wir später
Entscheidungen treffen müssen,
werden wir für sie da sein
und helfen.
Aus diesem Grund
erlaube ich mir, zu scherzen:
"Zwei bei Mica und eine bei mir."
Egal wie sie sich entscheidet,
wir werden für sie da sein.
Sie war immer für uns da,
sie half uns immer.
Ich komme jeden Mittag,
helfe, wie ich kann,
aber wir werden auf jeden Fall
da sein.
Hallo, meine Tochter.
* Entspannte Gitarrenklänge *
Il n'y a pas des ampoules?
- Non.
Ça va être beau?
- Il faut en faire des troux.
Seinerzeit
wollte sie nach Portugal zurück.
Wie ich sie kenne,
wäre sie hier glücklicher,
aber sie sagt,
es sei schwieriger mit ihrer Rente.
Wir werden versuchen, ihr zu helfen.
Ich denke,
sie wäre hier glücklicher als dort.
All ihre Schwestern und Brüder,
die wieder dorthingegangen sind,
fühlen sich ...
etwas einsam und verbittert
und grau.
Ja,
bestimmt wäre sie glücklicher hier
mit ihren Kindern und Grosskindern.
Wie auch immer sie sich entscheiden
wird, wir unterstützen sie.
Aber da ich denke,
dass sie hier glücklicher wäre,
helfe ich ihr gerne, wenn ich kann,
sich hier zurechtzufinden.
Wir werden sehen.
- Mach dir keine Sorgen.
Gute Wahl, meine Liebe, sehr schön!
Danke, mein Herz.
Und ich?
Wollte mich eben bedanken.
Mit der Unterstützung meiner Kinder
wollte ich meine zweite Säule
beziehen und nach Portugal gehen,
um dort etwas zu kaufen.
Hier weiss ich nicht,
wie hoch meine Rente sein wird,
das macht mir Angst.
In dieser Wohnung
kann ich nicht bleiben.
Ich will mich nicht aufdrängen,
bei meinen Kindern zu wohnen.
Aber meine Tochter sagt:
"Mama,
was willst du alleine in Portugal?
"Wenn mein Bruder und ich
dir helfen, kannst du hierbleiben."
Ich weiss es nicht.
Die Zukunft wird es zeigen.
Ja, ich denke viel daran,
aber ich will ebenfalls,
dass meine Kinder zufrieden sind.
Ich kann mir kaum vorstellen,
wegzugehen und sie zurückzulassen.
Mit meiner Rente werde ich nicht die
Möglichkeit haben, hierzubleiben.
Die Kinder werden ihr eigenes Leben
führen und selber Kinder haben.
Das nagt an mir.
* Sentimentale Gitarrenklänge *
Wird Manuela weggehen müssen?
Seit 2010 ist die Einwanderung
der Portugiesen rückgängig.
Es gibt mehr Vorteile
für die Portugiesen,
die wegziehen, als für diejenigen,
die in die Schweiz kommen.
Der Wirtschaft in Portugal
geht es besser
und das Rentnerleben in der Schweiz
ist viel zu teuer.
Das ist auch der Fall
von Tiagos Eltern.
Tiago ist als Neunjähriger
in die Schweiz gekommen.
Er ist vollkommen Vaudois, Hauswart
im Universitätsspital in Lausanne,
verheiratet mit einer Portugiesin,
zwei Kinder.
Seine Eltern sind vor knapp
sechs Monaten zurückgekehrt.
Hallo, wie geht's?
Gut und dir?
- Wie geht es Papa?
Es geht ihm gut,
er ist draussen im Garten.
Lass ihn, ist nicht schlimm.
Ist alles gut im Haus?
- Ja.
Warst du am Strand am Wochenende?
War's schön? War schönes Wetter?
Es ist so schön am Strand
und tut so gut.
Hören wir uns morgen?
- Vielleicht heute Abend?
Oder heute Abend.
Um mit den Kleinen zu sprechen
- Okay, tschau, Küsschen.
Tschau, schönen Nachmittag.
Telefonieren Sie öfter?
Ja, eigentlich jeden Mittag
während des Mittagessens.
Ist das Ihr kleines Ritual?
- Ja, das ist schön.
Ihre Eltern
möchten nicht darauf verzichten?
Ich denke, das wäre hart. Es ist
schon hart genug, weg zu sein.
So können wir uns wenigstens sehen.
Es ist, als seien sie hier,
ohne wirklich hier zu sein.
Das macht es erträglicher.
Meine Eltern sind schon weg,
diesen Sommer
werden meine Schwiegereltern gehen
und wir beide bleiben dann
alleine hier, ohne unsere Eltern.
Wir fragen uns,
ob wir gehen oder bleiben sollen,
um diesen endlosen Teufelskreis
zu unterbrechen.
Meine Eltern
haben ihre Eltern verlassen,
um mit ihren Kindern
hierherzukommen.
Jetzt gehen sie,
und ich bleibe mit meinen Kindern.
Wenn ich bis zu meiner Pensionierung
bleibe und dann gehe,
werden meine Kinder hierbleiben.
Man fragt sich, was das soll.
Den Teufelskreis der Zerrissenheit
aufhalten -
eine Frage, die in der Gemeinschaft
omnipräsent ist.
Les dames qui ont gagné la
première place, deuxième place ...
Joue! T'as vu qu'il a un ace?
Tiens, quatre.
Ça, c'est qui ne faut pas ramasser.
In Marias Familie dreht sich alles
um die Pensionierung.
Il n'y a pas mes cartes.
On y va.
- Mais non, c'est qui qui a joué ça?
José Louis
wird in zwei Jahren pensioniert,
aber sogar für ihn als Maurer
mit einem Verdienst von 6'000 Fr.
wird es schwierig sein.
Papas Rente beträgt etwas mehr
als 2'000.- Du noch 50 %.
Ich verdiene etwas mehr als 2'000.
Kann man mit 4'000 hier leben?
Nein.
Mit 65 gehe ich nach Portugal.
Ich bleibe nicht hier.
Philip wird wahrscheinlich bleiben,
Paula vielleicht.
Ich kenne nur das,
ich werde bleiben.
Ich bin hier gross geworden,
ich liebe die Stadt.
In Portugal leben wir ländlicher.
Im Moment ist es noch zu früh,
um an meine Pensionierung zu denken,
ich habe ja erst angefangen.
Macht es dir etwas aus,
dass wir gehen?
Ich denke, es ist besser für sie,
denn hier wird es kompliziert sein.
Es macht mir schon zu schaffen.
Uns gefällt es trotz allem gut hier,
wir fühlen uns wohl,
wir wurden in diesem Land empfangen,
haben eine gute Ausbildung
und gute Arbeit.
Z.B. meinem Papa
gefällt es sehr gut hier.
Die Vorstellung, weggehen zu müssen
und seine Pensionierung
nicht hier geniessen zu können,
weil man nicht für sich aufkommen
kann, ist schon irgendwie traurig.
Er hat seine Freunde
und Beschäftigungen hier,
ist ebenfalls Mitglied
verschiedener Vereine.
Auf all das müsste er verzichten.
Das ist traurig.
Zum Zeitpunkt der Pensionierung
ist eine portugiesische Familie
mit einem zweiten Exil konfrontiert.
In der Einsamkeit ihrer Wohnung ist
der grosse Tag für Isabel gekommen.
Mit 60 Jahren
bleibt nicht mehr viel Zeit.
Sie muss demnächst eine Rückkehr
in ihre Heimat ins Auge fassen.
Ich freue mich,
in meine Heimat zurückzukehren,
mein Haus wiederzusehen,
das ist ein grosser Moment für mich
und bedeutet mir viel.
Was erwarten Sie,
wenn Sie in dieses Haus gehen?
Das ist schwer zu sagen,
ich habe keine Familie mehr dort.
Ich finde es schön,
das Haus wiederzusehen,
in dem ich mit meiner Mutter
und Tante gelebt habe.
Was erhoffen Sie sich davon?
Wenn ich die Möglichkeit hätte,
das Haus zu renovieren,
würde ich gerne
meine verbleibende Zeit
in meiner Heimat verbringen.
(Durchsage)
Votre attention, s'il vous plaît,
votre vol EasyJet 631453
à destination de Porto ...
* Verspielte Gitarrenklänge *
Hallo, guten Tag, wie geht's?
Es geht. Ich falle immer wieder hin.
Und wie läuft's bei dir?
* Entferntes Gespräch,
ein Hahn kräht. *
* Ein Hund bellt. *
* Sie sprechen portugiesisch. *
Isabel ist seit dem Tod ihrer Mutter
nicht zurückgekommen.
Das Haus wurde seitdem
nie wieder betreten.
Nichts hat sich verändert.
* Die Tür knarrt leise. *
* Quietschen *
Das ist das Zimmer meiner Mutter,
hier haben wir geschlafen.
Im selben Bett?
Ja, im Winter war es kalt.
Das Haus hatte keine Heizung.
Um uns gegenseitig warmzuhalten,
haben wir im gleichen Bett
geschlafen.
Es ist Februar.
Es ist sehr feucht im Haus,
es herrscht ein moderiger Geruch.
Alles ist sehr heruntergekommen.
* Sentimentale Klänge *
Es ist traurig.
Ich bin traurig, das Haus
in diesem Zustand wiederzusehen.
Es wird zerfallen,
wenn nichts gemacht wird,
das ist klar,
aber das stimmt mich traurig.
Das hatten Sie nicht erwartet?
Ein wenig schon,
aber nicht in diesem Ausmass.
Es ist seit über zehn Jahren
nicht mehr bewohnt.
Es zerfällt immer mehr.
Die Mauern sind beschädigt,
es ist feucht.
Unmöglich, in diesem Zustand
darin zu leben.
In Anbetracht Ihrer finanziellen
Situation in der Schweiz
und diesem Haus, denken Sie, dass
sich Ihr Traum in Nichts auflöst?
Ja.
Im Moment habe ich keine
Möglichkeit, das Haus zu renovieren.
Und nun?
- Ich werde nicht herkommen.
* Melancholische Gitarrenklänge *
* Ein Hund bellt, ein Hahn kräht. *
Am anderen Ende von Portugal,
bei Lissabon,
haben die Eltern von Tiago
mehr Glück.
Aber ob das wirklich Glück ist?
Die Farbe ist noch frisch,
der Garten in Arbeit.
Junge Pensionierte in ihrem Haus,
gekauft von ihrer zweiten Säule.
Antonio und Paula bauen sich
ein neues Leben auf.
Ganz alleine.
Wir haben Zimmer
für die Kinder bereitgestellt,
sogar mit Badezimmer,
damit sie uns besuchen
und sich wohlfühlen können.
Es ist wichtig,
dass alle ihr eigenes Zimmer haben.
Hallo.
- Hallo, wie geht's?
Gut, und dir?
- Bestens, dir?
Gut, und Papa auch.
Guten Tag, mein Lieber.
Und läuft's mit der Arbeit?
Ja, ja, es geht.
Papa arbeitet im Garten,
streicht die Aussenmauer,
an Arbeit fehlt es ihm nicht.
Ist doch gut, so bleibt er dran.
Man muss sich beschäftigen.
Ich hatte noch keine Zeit,
die Papiere der Krankenversicherung
zu schicken.
Hast du sie noch nicht geschickt?
- Nein, keine Zeit.
Das musst du dringend machen.
Ich habe die Zahlungsaufforderungen
bereits blockiert.
Ist alles blockiert.
In diesem neuen Leben
kommt unnötiger,
administrativer Stress dazu.
Die portugiesische Regierung
verkündet das Ende
der zehnjährigen Steuerbefreiung
für ausländische oder für
ins Land zurückgekehrte Rentner.
Zum Glück sind sie
nicht davon betroffen.
Ihre Sorge betrifft
die Krankenversicherung.
Die Schweiz verlangt
die Begleichung der Rechnungen,
obwohl sie seit sechs Monaten
in Portugal versichert sind.
Ich bin etwas verloren.
Sie verpflichten mich
und meinen Mann,
1'000 Fr. zu bezahlen -
1'000 Fr., das stresst mich.
Wenn ich nicht bezahle,
werden sie mich betreiben
und ich werde gebüsst.
Mein Sohn hat angerufen, er spricht
besser Französisch als ich.
Er hat alles erklärt,
wie es sich in Portugal verhält.
Er sagte mir, die Schweiz
sei das komplizierteste Land.
Wir sind hier weit entfernt
von einer idealen Pensionierung.
Schon nach sechs Monaten
kommt Langeweile auf.
Paula taucht
in ihre Erinnerungen ein,
denkt an die Zeit
vor der Pensionierung
und an die Zeit in der Kinderkrippe
voller Leben,
als sie als Putzfrau arbeitete.
Arbeiteten Sie lange
in dieser Krippe?
14 Jahre.
Ich habe sehr schöne Erinnerungen.
Sie waren sehr zufrieden
mit meiner Arbeit.
Sich daran zu erinnern, tut gut.
Es waren ja doch ein paar Jährchen.
Ich erinnere mich,
wie sie immer sagten,
ich sei voller Energie und fleissig.
Und jetzt?
Was kann ich hier schon machen?
Ich habe nichts zu tun.
Mein Mann arbeitet
ein wenig im Garten, und ich?
Ich langweile mich schon
ein bisschen.
Fühlen Sie sich etwas verloren?
Ja, genau: ein wenig verloren.
So fühle ich mich.
* Melancholische Gitarrenklänge *
Ich habe weder Freunde
noch Freundinnen hier,
ich kenne ja niemanden.
Ich fühle ich mich
wie eine Einwandererin.
Zuerst bin ich
in die Schweiz ausgewandert
und jetzt bin ich
nach Portugal ausgewandert.
Wenn ich meinen Sohn anrufe,
reden wir darüber,
dass ich mich hier einsam fühle.
Um café tranquilo.
Bonj... Bom dia.
- Bom dia.
Aus Reflex spricht man Französisch.
Man sagt bonjour oder fragt etwas.
Anstatt Euro zu sagen,
sagt man Franken.
Manchmal habe ich Angst, dass die
Leute denken, ich sei Schweizerin.
Wir trinken Kaffee.
Am Nachmittag gehen wir an
den Strand.-Bei uns schneit es.
Zeig, wir wollen den Schnee sehen.
- Schau, der Schnee.
Es schneit sehr stark.
Der Schnee fehlt uns.
Trotz dieser idyllischen Landschaft
vermisst Paula den Schnee
und die Schweizer Berge.
Dazu kommt das Gefühl, von einem Land
ungerecht behandelt zu werden,
das nicht imstande ist, ihnen
eine ordentliche Rente anzubieten -
sowohl den Portugiesinnen
als auch den Schweizerinnen.
* Melancholische Celloklänge *
Und wie fühlen Sie sich hier?
Mit dem Kopf bin ich noch
in der Schweiz.
95 % meiner Freunde und Freundinnen
sind dort.
Das ist normal,
ich hatte da viele Kontakte.
Sie fehlen mir.
Aber so ist das Leben.
In der Schweiz
war ich ein glücklicher Mensch.
Nun geht es darum, auch hier
weiterhin glücklich zu sein.
Was denken Sie, ist Paula glücklich?
Ja, sie wird sich daran gewöhnen.
Sie braucht noch ein Jahr,
dann ist es gut.
Ich lebe besser,
aber ...
Es gibt eben immer ein Aber.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
Michaela Hoss - 2021